les chéris c'est très simple aujourd'hui
le jeu du jour et bâle sachez que les
soldes des comptes croquembouche je me
suis pas du tout rentrer des joueurs des
mâles molle d'accord comme toi casta
pourquoi la voulons vous lancer la balle
vous aurez trois balles regardez à 2 3
vous là vous la faites rouler il y a
donc un petit ballet l'âme et il faut
bien mettre le maximum de points celui
qui aura mis le plus de points en trois
balles trop belle sera contre moi en
finale vous pouvez perso j'ai bien sûr
chez vous c'est rien c'est bien sûr tu
pouvais lui en pvc
voilà on voyait qu'ils assureront le bac
comme le dit la productrice puisqu'elle
a pas écouté mes explications
1.2.3 voilà est devait-on en train de
bouffer fusionnelle fans le dieu
[Applaudissements]
m
vas-y jean-michel alliant exemple c'est
plus prochaine non non non premier
budget comme ça attention ce soir qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de la faire rouler
il va rentrer chez lui combien dessin
[Applaudissements]
l'appel à saqba la claque pour tous mais
le gagnant kim affrontera jean michel2
avant obtenez avant deux points région
pour l'enterrer moi parce que j'ai pas
retenu à l'époque tout le monde
malheureusement dérange pas là pour ça
géraldine bien chéri du radi qui est
magnifique sublime alors est content que
vous soyez là bas j'ai zappé la croatie
qui contente puisque vert au club ils se
font beaucoup plus facilement well as
pas comme ça quand je suis comme ça
alors non mais oh jésus qui te prend
chérie c'est historique ce que tu vas me
faire déchirer
non pas pour toi c'est pas salé pour
l'assaut c'est jean-michel avec deux
points mérités non nous le rappelle
naulleau la caution structure de cette
admission à ça soit pas trop si bâti
basse et de la culture ça c'est de la
culture m'a dit mon chéri complètement
taré luz le garder chez lui il fait de
la muscu avec isabelle morini bosc et
ceux qui sont passé s'il vous plaît à
droite gilles michel pour l'instant qui
est un qualifié isabelle vient cherry a
mis une demi-heure
milan impossible non pour venir ouais
le badminton
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît castany voilà castaldi
toujours la place l'élégance toujours
cette démarche féline
quelles démarches freddy bout de ma
gueule encore mais non mais qu'elle fait
bien ce mec va dé moi chérie je le sens
bien j'ai dit que j'étais préparé
tebbane mes débuts il prend ton temps tu
entends bébé mais tardive à tenir debout
si oui c'est bon c'est vrai équilibre
tourne tellement que j'en savais bien
oui maintenant que tu es une porte d'une
jambe et manquent de zulu vous avez
remarqué je vous prépare beaubois merci
alors si les spams and see you pay
là-bas de boules en même temps elle
retour il vise à l'aise il ya une autre
des grands clubs
pourtant calé prends ton temps chéri ben
je crois que ça suffira pas contre
sochaux
moissinac la caméra tous et bon d'accord
c'est entre jean michel et je vous
rappelle qu'il ya une règle c'est le
plus jeune qui est qualifié voilà je
vais pas là non non j'ai donc on fera
enfreint une boule mais là ils me
servent à way et tu fais la finale non
merci vraiment le sens très très bien
non cash de plantes et balmont 3e tiers
ouais je te prends tes boules bret a
bien fait bravo attention mais ce jeu
c'est un truc que je peux faire ça à 8
heures ça c'est pas de chance et le 3
alors j'étais la dernière chose et si
l'on sert la joue entre jean michel
isabelle pour m'affronter
ouais je rappelle #obama la platière
magnifiques cadeaux à gagner là quoi
gagner merci ils sont morts enrichi
valait pas le dire une caméra sport
waterproof et où le toit bien sûr mais
pro tu tires authier si doucement à
chebba oui mais oui mais on s'est dit
toi
[Applaudissements]
en une boule en humour oui mais
attention si vous ratez tous les doigts
vous aurez le boul si j'avais isabelle
non gens me bats des mouchards vas-y mon
bébé il savait qu'il faudra lire à 10
aux tirs ta boule au tirage au sort
non si isabelle mais gagner il avait la
gagne et sinon vous serez tous les deux
contre moi d'accord
là bas vous êtes tous les deux contre
ben on sait la finale isabelle et jean
louis brossard série isabelle vous
démarrez trésor attention cet article
on va voir comment ne pas vous faites en
5.5 paddock deux boules trois boules
pour isabelle lorsque tu es galon et
deux boules pour toi de dollars et 3
mais c'est pas grave de boules pour
l'attraper c'est très sympa pour isa
donc vous avez deux points
deux points dont l'équipe isabelle
janvier
on a donc de quoi ça va passer forcément
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe florès une dh et
non attention ça ce jour d'une boule
venait là jusqu'à d'innovation y aller
28 jours mais ces gens me que vous
choisissez attention si je la mets si je
la mets c'est terminé et malheureusement
vous serez mené 2.0 ce qui veut dire que
vous allez en chier en fin de semaine à
mon avis il avait sans doute en ligne
précise alors prends ton temps bercy
s'est pas échappé des mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gagné elle doit gagner les trois donc à
mon avis ça va être chaud pour vous les
chéris remettez vous en question